all right I'm gonna fly between these
buildings up here said I wish me good
business well if I if we gave you this
wishy Cesar are the best business wishes
oh no no it's not gonna work no no no I
lost it I lost a wing imac business bail
go
can the business update is out it is
said and you're the best thing about it
it's free it's free and that's a rare
thing in business education money
costing things rubbish let's like show
off all the cooler stuff you can get in
this update set by being the Wolves of
Wall Street awesome yeah we're gonna
have to get dressed for it though okay
let's go look we're right outside
address place let's go all right I mean
I mean it's closed let's go to a
different one different shop this
clothing Shore must surely be open for
business oh gosh you killed me yes [ __ ]
whoopsie-daisy I was so close to getting
the clothes I wanted cameras a fine day
to be a businessman and I don't think
you've quite got the point of this was
gonna say I look a bit different from
you you said wolf right the walls the
wolves are businessmen well whatever i'm
not changing we need to get rich okay so
i get to be rich he's gonna be good
wolves right so let's do that let's get
rich well we're loaded that was easy why
don't more people just do that oh look
at the wolf marks on the side of my car
sab is this y'all let you out here get
out get out rich man nice now so I my
top hat broke my policy so have car
shoppings fun yeah I am gonna take the
Alpha so I can be an alpha wolf oh hello
there it is hello sweet ride Jesus look
at that hello hot mama I could look at
that hotness much cam I I like that much
like my suit with its clashing brown and
orange oh my new ride as a class spurts
a clashing orange and red right look how
sleep I like that is very that's got the
coat of a wolf successful business
wolves to do it mind you so sorry no I'm
marking it lik I've given you a wolf
mark that's why we know where will you
scratch them know right look let me let
me show you i will get at the car and
show you look at the look at the wolf
mark on the front and off of your shine
i'm showing you the wolf mart oh god
there's a no-show look so sorry ah yeah
these are delicious mmm-hmm okay I'm
just gonna have a quick smoke as well Oh
crud oh god are you what have you done
oh I've hit everything high by now
you've overtaken me have hostile
takeover yes oh god oh god eek estrella
Oh salve your car your ride you idiot
wolf reverse oh no sticks oh I'm so
close yeah Mike my top hat go wet oh no
so have a morning your tweed my tweed
this means war sir now that's gonna be
my car crossing the line see my finger
is the car and the circle is the low
cable look over look how many times I
cross the line before you a business
trip first business trip together so
wait this is part of this is the
business updates she's a part of a
business update gate I thought it was
yeah if the clue is in the word business
I don't think even crashing at all might
have oh oh oh god oh no I wolf left my
way into some trees uh-oh survivor that
was good i have a problem eight seconds
God's this not really done for three no
so please come on oh just read it oh
that was so close just in time that's uh
that's real business oh that's real
badman she exactly business businessman
ship all right here pal all right why oh
yeah oh hello fellow wolf come good wolf
dive thank you I'm not sure they gonna
let you in here dude easy sir a rich man
let me a hat like that i'm not sure your
address with oh well you just let you in
I said I said one more wolf drink don't
know what but I can look at me look at
me grow are all right thank you that
yeah hey I'm a wolf visions kicking in
sir my night vision hello I'm looking
for a beautiful white I find yourself a
wife I'm a very rich wolf man don't you
know where'd she go uh I I believe this
lady is stolen my hat is she all I know
is that my hat is gone lady give me my
hat back hold still you may be my wife
first not even my wife is allowed to
steal I stopped moving our sep this next
one is vulture capital yeah which I
guess oh I get it I see what
because when you're a business will fly
cus you how are you doing he's dancing
some good dance is groovy when you're a
business wolf like we are and you you
become the capital of the city right you
become the capital city right yeah and
we're and weird vultures picking at the
wretched carcass Los Santos is
financials yeah let's do that let's pick
this carcass let's pick the carcass
what's the order of business today said
its death its missile got doc you're
sure it is yeah business missiles well
business oh [ __ ] did I hear you amazing
my business corpse to keep checking
under I just learned it carefully here
easy corporate Jenks all right I'm gonna
fly between these buildings up here said
I wish me good business well if I if we
give you business wishy Cesar are the
best business wishes oh no no it's not
gonna work no no no I lost it I lost a
wing I my business bail no go shake this
weird [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh God quick palau I
saw that high speed high G pull out all
right did you make it I just saw you go
down okay yeah yeah I made it don't pick
me up I can hear you he come [ __ ] let's
see okay I believe it yes oh let's put
the wheels down this is a good as cool
as cool school there's a runway here
I've cleared the runway for you and you
come slow down slow down slow don't mind
it landed London London London ah oh
well time I'm slightly on fire it's
alright ice that's a landing fire all
right it just means you've landed well
sorry it's just that let me look at the
damage these the fires of business afar
yeah that's going out if anything is
going out yeah he's am sorry okay so
there's a little lamp post on top the
fire is getting worse no it's not it's
um I worse or better watch me off guide
you run me over no it's okay it's okay
Oh getting all right we got a fresh bit
of runway just did you literally just
lost your way no it's alright we can
still get it get in and trying all right
i mean i mean it's all intensive
purposes a min let's go
ah let's get to fly safe look oh it's
darling no I felt felt like a wolf to
find flying there pal come on you're
almost there you've always got in the
end you've almost got there keep going
get her lip he'll upset pull up come on
like our stocks and shares going up funk
she's good this on state get me in the
air I'm doing it all right we can do
this yes we're actually getting speed
yeah come on come on pull up pull up I'm
pulling up pull up I'm pulling the
sideways oh yes yes it works oh no guys
oh I think we died
you